hey today we're going to be looking at
lighting in 3.js
exploring the different light types and
how to add lighting to your scenes in
javascript
getting the lighting right in any 3d
scene is really challenging
and so having a lot of options of
lighting types can come in really handy
what we'll cover today is the different
light types that 3.js offers
and we'll go over them one by one and
explore how they work
how to use 3js lights in code and
finally how they're typically used in
major games
before we start like always make sure
you're subscribed hit that subscribe
button and the like button
really helps me out also follow me on
twitter since it's an easy way to get in
contact with me and see what i'm working
on next
anyway let's go over the different light
types we're just using the same setup
that we used for the basic 3d world
so check that out if you don't already
know how to set this all up
we'll start with the soft lights that
sort of mimic indirect lighting
kind of a poor men's global illumination
first up the ambient light this is a
super simple and easy to use and
understand light
all it does is equally brighten
everything in the scene
there's not much to go over here it's
basically just adding a constant
brightness and color to everything
in code this is just a simple
instantiation of an ambient light
with the color and intensity as
parameters then we need to add it to the
scene
you can see it here on the sphere it
just adds constant color to the scene
and if we change the color of the
ambient light everything changes
normally you'd use these to just add a
tiny bit of light for shadowed areas
so if i had a bright sunlight casting a
shadow you can add an ambient light to
get that kind of bounce light
hemisphere lighting is kind of
interesting it's specified using two
different colors
one for above and one from below then
you interpolate between them based on
the normal's direction without
using the sky color and down using the
ground color
the code's pretty simple you just
instantiate an instance of a hemisphere
light
set the two colors in this case we're
going to use a yellowish color for the
sky
and bluish color for the ground when we
load this up and
observe this on the sphere you can see
the top and bottom are lit differently
so what's this typically used for in my
experience i've seen this used in a
place of ambient lighting for outdoor
scenes since in shattered areas you'd
still get a bit of detail from lighting
now the wrecked area light is really
interesting this is a soft rectangular
light
that can be used to fill scenes with
diffuse semi-directional light
under the hood this is actually really
complicated and there's a whole sig
graph paper on the technique used
in code this is slightly more
complicated you need to instantiate an
instance of erect area light with the
color and intensity as always
but you also need to supply a width and
a height so in this case we've supplied
widths of 2.0 and length of 20.0
so when we load this up you'll see a
long strip of light
and you could imagine this being very
useful in situations where you've got
indoor scenes and you want some sort of
soft ambient lighting in rooms
an easy example is a bright tv screen
directional lights are kind of a
simplification of sunlight
you can imagine an object in the world
and sunlight all the rays are basically
parallel
the sun is almost like a source of light
that's infinitely far away
so that all the light reaching you is
basically all going in the exact same
direction
directional light calculation is pretty
straightforward just a simple
n-dot l for diffuse lighting
interestingly enough
this is the first type of light that
we've talked about that supports shadows
the others are softer less directional
approximations of light so calculating
the shadow contribution
isn't straightforward but for a
directional light from the point of view
of the sun
it's just this area behind an object so
it's easy
in code they're easy to instantiate and
manipulate
create an instance of a directional
light with color and intensity
parameters
and then you can just position it make
sure when you add it to the scene to
also add the light's target
you can see here that we've got a sphere
and if we set the directional light
it lights up from one direction now if
we were to change the scene slightly
say have multiple spheres notice how
they're all lit from the same angle and
direction
in games outdoor scenes the major light
source being the sun will usually be a
directional light with shadow maps
point lights are just lights that have a
specific position and emit light in
every direction
instead of directional lights which sort
of are treated as being infinitely far
away
point lights have a very real defined
location
when calculating them in shader code
they're almost identical to directional
lights
except that you're calculating the
direction yourself and you may be
applying some dimming the further from
the light you are
in code you instantiate a point light
with color and intensity
and then assign it a position that's all
there's a decay parameter too if you
want to play with the falloff but
leaving at the defaults is fine for now
now once we load the scene up you can
see that this sphere and the ground are
getting light from the point light
if we go and change the scene to have
multiple spheres they're getting lit
from the light between them now
in games point lights are pretty
versatile a torch
an explosion they're kind of a jack of
all trades light
finally spotlights while point lights
have a specific position
they don't have any direction they just
emit light everywhere
spotlights have a specific position and
a direction
like a flashlight if you're implementing
a spotlight yourself they're pretty
simple
very similar to point lights in fact but
you're going to decay both with the
distance from the spotlight
and with the angle between the point and
the light and the light's direction
in code you instantiate a spotlight with
color and intensity
but there's a few more parameters to
play with here you need to supply the
distance or range of the light
and then there's the angle of dispersion
and the penumbra you can think of them
as how wide the spotlight is and how
sharp it is
there's also a decay parameter that
affects how fast the light dims with
distance
and the default is usually fine let's
look at some examples
so if i load this up to start we see it
shining down
let's go and narrow the angle of
dispersion so we'll just divide this by
two
now when we load this up voila much
narrower
let's put that back the way it was but
we'll increase the penumbra value a bit
so the light falls off near the edges
the valid range is zero to one so we'll
just jack it up to one and you can see
that the light falls off towards the
edges
and of course in game flashlight being
the most obvious use for a spotlight
anyway that should cover the basics of
what 3gs has to offer
in terms of lights hope you enjoyed this
if you haven't already subscribe both
here and on twitter
you'll get notifications for when new
videos drop and previews on what's
coming up next
make sure to like the video and leave a
comment about what you want to see
covered in a future tutorial
the code is all up on github so knock
yourself out do whatever you want with
it
doesn't matter it's free to use if you
don't understand anything
just ask me cheers